playing at a home a rather slav
definitely a great way to start with the
game against a former world champion
Magnus Carlson and what a victory that
was tell us a bit about that game and
how did you approach the opening after
he surprised you let's say with the
Polish opening yeah actually he uh
surprised me but
um
it wasn't a surprise
as I expected a surprise I didn't really
know if it will be some sort of a benoni
or something like that but then when he
played B5 I just thought okay let's play
let's do some normal moves but my
Approach was to play active chess and
this this is what I what I thought gave
me
gave me a victory because I uh I played
actively especially this
D5 we can just take a look at the game
yeah I thought that when he went Bishop
p7 if I don't do anything uh fastkey he
will he will just go D6 and castle and
obviously I'm uh better but I thought
that after D5 I'm uh the site which is
uh playing for like uh
yeah this opening not like that because
he's very very uh
strong of course but when you see
something like this you
don't want to go for some uh maneuvering
game because if you can go D5 and
obviously it looks very nice at first so
I thought that why not we had a full uh
audience there so I thought let's play
something let's go for it yeah for them
and and uh yeah after after that I
thought that Bishop 86 was uh important
to stop short Castle
and when he went through G8 uh Visa P3
back because now there is no option to
uh sarcasm and uh this position was very
very bad but uh but then he was
defending tenaciously of course he's
probably one of the best defenders yeah
yeah and yeah I mean then then after
this
seeks this position I really liked but
then after Knight H5 I realized that I
have to defend F6 pawn and I didn't
really see exactly how and that's why I
went uh Queen C3 and after Rook d8 was
very uh important moment because my move
uh A3 looks like something which doesn't
really strike as a good move but I
didn't really see a better one and the
idea is that he is threatening before
before let's say you go G3 here yeah if
I go something like G3 he goes B4 Queen
E5 and now he goes D6 and I have to go
back let I mean let's say here and then
after Knight F6 at least he got his
these are not clear yes yeah yes that's
why that's why I went for this A3 uh
which doesn't look uh
impressive but uh also it
it felt that Magnus simply here he
doesn't have active moves so that's why
I thought I can afford it and then after
uh G3
uh I went G5 around here I wasn't sure
because uh obviously with uh engine is a
very very simple also I uh obviously I
knew that I'm winning so but you're also
getting down on time and that's yeah
that was a problem no pressure yes yes
yes especially that after uh Rook G5
this is the moment I really wasn't sure
how to proceed because obviously it
looks excellent probably there are like
many many moves but you have to go for
one yeah which is you have options yes
yes yes right now sometimes it's uh not
ideal and uh I decided to go for uh
Bishop D3 probably the best move yeah
yeah rookie five and Knight F5 and uh
the thing is that I'm losing F6 Pawn but
uh there are so many threads
uh after a queen before
uh that I didn't really see how he can
defend a specialty that after D6 Queen
C3 uh F6 is hanging I thought during the
game that maybe he could play something
like Knight G8 but obviously if you have
to play Knight Jade
you know things went wrong very very
wrong
yeah yeah but I thought that uh when he
went B5 I actually made a very good uh
[Music]
choice that I should play active because
obviously if I would play some normal uh
game
um we would maneuver and in the long
game obviously Magnus there are not so
many players who can play against him so
I thought that I should go all in and
this worked out and it wasn't
that's a hard in a sense that obviously
D5 is a is an idea which actually looks
very very nice so that was a great
decision initial decision in game one
and that definitely gave you a boost of
confidence after that I think you
defeated you defend it quite well
against Richie absolutely no problems
with the black pieces definitely a
successful day one for you for sure and
we'll see you tomorrow
thank you Christian and indeed
understanding stuff